[Musique]
vous savez comment on dit bonjour la
langue nationale du sénégal
alors je vais vous dire quand je vais
vous dire ma greffe
vous allez dire marie fille nine des
mercis vous connaissez aussi le pays de
la téranga le au sud du sénégal le pays
de la téranga le pays du partage et de
l'hospitalité le pays des grands hommes
religieux comme sidina limamou laye
mumbai est sur youtube à ma moto est
impatient quel est le rôle de la femme
dans l'agriculture
la fin est le socle de la société la
femme est l'actif clé du développement
elle passait pour développement socio
économique du pays 80 % des denrées
alimentaires fait en afrique
subsaharienne
ce sont les femmes qui les produisent
90% des cultures céréalières comme le
riz le blé le maïs ce sont aussi les
femmes qui passait sur toute la chaîne
de valeur de la production à la
commercialisation à penser à voir la
transformation et les femmes travaillent
énormément
67% des heures de travail les femmes qui
le consacrent au travail
c'est énorme est ce que l'afrique va
faire face à un challenge démographie
durant ces dernières années nous ôtons
nous notons une croissance exponentielle
de la population mondiale et selon des
projections fulgurante la population
mondiale serait de 8 milliards en 2025
selon oddo met en scène pour nourrir
toutes ces populations
on a besoin d'une agriculture qui est
moderne massif et diversifiée vu
l'impact positif de la femme dans la
société
nous pensons que c'est le point nommé de
voir l'implication des femmes dans le
secteur où est ce que mon histoire est
entré en danse
tout est parti à qui tu du goût une
ville qui à 702 km de dakar une ville
touristique de par ses cascades les
cascades de dindéfélo mais aussi le parc
national de niokolo koba une ville
d'agriculteurs et un russe dont les
terres sont fertiles
j'avais l'habitude de travailler avec un
groupement de femmes de 7 500 femmes qui
sont aux ardeurs de fadiga d'habitude
les femmes travailler de 6h à 19h il
était une fois on était en train de
faire des sciences de pépinières la
pluie il commençait à pleuvoir
comment on était stressés dans un jardin
de deux hectares y avait pas de bien
vécu des plantations
on ne savait pas où se mettre ont
commencé à pleurer
moi j'ai commencé à dérouler son mandat
et dans ma langue nationale
on pensait que c'est la mort mais quand
la pluie s'est arrêtée
c'était juste pour vous dire que dans la
vie il faut quel que soit leur statut
il faut dire que ça va y aller il faut
penser positivement et dire que peu
importe ça va aller étant élevé par un
père cultivateur
j'ai toujours eu la passion de la tête
et je rejoigne et quotidiennement mon
père aussi familial d'ailleurs c'est là
que j'ai eu carrément la passion de la
terre et je disais à mes amis que je
serai à grenon orient après l'obtention
de mon baccalauréat scientifique
je me suis inscrite dans une école de
formation agronomique
je suis actuellement bas chaleur en
agronomie agrobusiness entrepreneurs
agricoles la présidente fondatrice de la
structure femmes à grenob du môle femmes
et la directrice de publication de
femmes magazine hello vie qui va de la
terre agricole fable la structure femme
agréable longue du monde a été créé en
février 2018 et regroupe l'ensemble des
femmes en gaz et qui s'active dans le
domaine agricole
ces derniers ont pour objectif de faire
de l'agriculture en juillet pour la
lutte pour la garante de la secteur
alimentaire en effet la population
mondiale connaît une croissance
exponentielle un boom démographique
on a besoin d'une agriculture qui est
moderne et massive pour nourrir de cette
population
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons avec des
groupements de femmes ont peu partout au
sénégal mais aussi à oran au mali et
deux pays africains nous promenons nous
voulons promouvoir le made in africa en
consommer ce que nous produisons mais
produisons ce que nous consommons
pour terminer j'aimerais juste dire à la
populaire à la à la jeunesse africaine
et surtout aux femmes de s'impliquer
davantage dans l'agriculture il ait de
la place pour tout le monde et la terre
ne ment pas il faut aussi que la
jeunesse fait que l'agriculture la terre
est le meilleur remède pour lutter
contre la mal la malnutrition
il faut s'impliquer davantage dans
l'agriculture il ya de la place pour
tout le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]